starwars stands huge in popular culture
and while opinions differ the 2010s have
given fans moments that make them cheer
cry and everything in between
here's our breakdown of the best Star
Wars moments of this last decade upon
first watching 2015's the force awakens
most fans were asking themselves the
same question most of the characters
struggled with throughout the film
where's Luke we simply do not have
enough information to locate Buster the
Jedi hero was nowhere to be seen for
most of the movie and it was enough to
make you wonder if he was going to show
up at all Luke's eventual portrayal in
the last Jedi would not be met with
universal praise for the moment at the
end of the force awakens in which Rey
finally meets the Jedi Master is
wonderfully done after finding all the
pieces of Luke's map and landing on the
remote island where Skywalker's hiding
out Rey climbs a crest to find him a
hooded cloaked figure as she holds out
the lightsaber to him Luke throws back
his hood and says nothing it's the
perfect ending that leaves you wanting
more you want to know why he's on the
island why he left the map fragments to
be found and whether or not he has any
idea what's been happening in his
absence
heck you kinda just want to know what
his voice sounds like these days
the force awakens brought with it the
heartbreaking death of one of the
original trilogy's favorite heroes the
original scruffy-looking nerf-herder
himself han Solo but before Han proves
he hasn't learned the important lesson
of staying off catwalks / bottomless
shafts the smuggler returns to the movie
screen exactly as he should with Rey and
Finn having stolen the Millennium Falcon
while escaping jakku they're snatched
out of space by a pursuer whom they
initially think is affiliated with the
first order instead it's a fan-favorite
duo from the original trilogy falling
carnivorous beasts before our younger
heroes can do anything to stop them han
and chewie pull the Falcon into the
hangar of their larger ship with a
tractor beam after an ominous series of
clangs and bangs the two storm on board
the legendary ship with guns drawn
once they don't see anyone han relaxes a
little smiles and says Chewie we're home
it's an awesome moment particularly for
fans of the original films it doesn't
come as much of a surprise as Hans line
was heavily used in the promotional
lead-up to the force awakens but it's
still tough not to cheer at least a
little when he delivers it we would be a
whole pack of scruffy-looking nerf
herders if we didn't mention perhaps the
most awe-inspiring and
merchandise promising Star Wars moments
of the decade the big reveal of baby
Yoda everything about the series feels
like a bleak western classic or a bloody
samurai epic with its hero being a gun
for hire who takes work from the
remnants of the empire even the
character who proves to be one of mandos
closest allies the diminutive queel
helps the bounty hunter in large part to
stop people like mando from coming to
his home once mando and the killer droid
IG 11 fight their way past the targets
guards it's a genuinely jaw-dropping
surprise to learn their target is an
infant and a floating egg a member of
the late Yoda's mysterious species the
reveal was an absolute master stroke and
the shot of baby Yoda's little hand
reaching Fernando's gloved finger is
sure to be burned into Star Wars fans
memories for years to come
with the exception of the digital
Princess Leia cameo the closest we got
to a Jedi hero in 2016's rogue one is
the warrior monk cheer at my charity is
not a Jedi himself but as a member of a
religious order charged with protecting
the temple of khyber charity understands
the poorest better than any of the
heroes of rogue one shortly after we
first meet him in spite of his blindness
cheer it beats the tar out of a squad of
stormtroopers harassing gin and casseon
throughout the film he repeats the
phrase the force is with me and I am
with the force often to the irritation
of his friend base it's precisely this
phrase that she retreats over and over
in the climactic scene of the film when
he makes it possible for the heroes to
contact the rebel fleet fighting in
orbit in spite of the council being on
the other side of a no-man's land filled
with laser fire turret picks up his
staff and repeats his credo while
walking into a storm of gun blasts
miraculously he survives the long walk
to the console and hits the right
switches allowing Bodie to contact the
rebel fleet and let them know to take
down the scare of planetary shield in
order to receive the Death Star plans
unfortunately charit dies moments later
when the console is destroyed but his
sacrifice remains one of the most
touching and iconic moments of the film
one of the best things about Solo a Star
Wars story is that it gives us a lot to
the Millennium Falcon still for anyone
who's seen the original trilogy they're
just waiting to find out when young Han
is going to win the thing from Lando
already if you've watched the Empire
Strikes Back then you know hon won the
Falcon fair and square in a card game
from Lando Calrissian
what have you done to my ship your ship
hey remember you lost her to me fair and
square once we find the younger versions
of both scoundrels looking at each other
from across a card table we think we're
finally about to see Hans famous win but
were wrong at least at first
Hans luck runs out at his first game of
soo bahk would land out but he joins
Beckett's crew anyway Lando later leaves
Han and his friends high and dry when it
looks like the Marauders are about to
take them out but Han doesn't forget the
ship he fell in love with in the final
moments of the film han tracks Lando
down snatches the card from the sleeve
gadget Lando thinks no one can see and
truly beats the rival smuggler fair and
square
it was the perfect note to end solo on
and it felt exactly how the card
showdown between these two reluctant
heroes should have played out by the end
of the force awakens we've watched kylo
Ren not only torture and kill innocents
but we've been forced to witness one of
the most heart-wrenching moments in Star
Wars the death of Han Solo at the hands
of his son but after killing Han and
almost doing the same thing to Finn kylo
Ren gets his just desserts on the snowy
surface of Starkiller base when rey
teaches him exactly what a jedi is
better still she does it with the
skywalker lightsaber a weapon that kylo
claims belongs to him the moment rey is
able to reach deep within herself and
achieve the column and confidence she
needs to defeat Han Solo's killer is one
of the most powerful scenes in the new
trilogy plus it's a truly beautiful shot
it's that much more powerful when you
remember that no one in the audience
knew exactly who the Jedi in this movie
was going to be there was a lot of smart
misdirection going on into the
promotional lead-up to the force awakens
most of the trailers and TV spots showed
Finn not Rey wielding the blue
lightsaber even going so far to feature
shots of the short duel between Finn and
kylo having died toward the end of the
last Jedi Luke Skywalker's force ghost
returns in the rise of Skywalker and his
entrance is perfect but leaving she's
lost any chance of finding the hidden
SIF planet of X Eagle and bearing her
potential for turning to the dark side
Rey swipes kylo ren's TIE fighter and
flies to Ock to the planet where she
finally discovered the dissolution Luke
Skywalker in the closing moments of the
force awakens after she initially
crashes the craft the TIE fighter is
being destroyed in a raging fire when
Rey takes out Luke's old lightsaber
she hurls it at the fire only to see
Luke's hand reach out and grabbed
weapon it's a powerful call back to the
earlier scene in the last Jedi win after
being offered his old lightsaber by Rey
Luke flings it behind him like garbage
now in the afterlife
Luke's clearly got a different
perspective if we still don't get the
reference Luke's force ghost drives the
point home by telling Rey that quotes a
Jedi's weapon deserves more respect and
in case the scene doesn't already have
fans applauding Luke uses the force to
lift his submerged x-wing out of the
water so reg can use it to get to exit
goal
we're immediately reminded of a similar
act that he fails at in the Empire
Strikes Back earning him a hard lesson
from Yoda at the end of the rise of
Skywalker Rey finds herself physically
alone in her confrontation with Emperor
Palpatine but in every other way she's
got plenty of company just like we found
her chanting in the beginning of the
film Rey repeats the phrase be with me
and finally she gets an answer that
reaches back to every corner of the
Skywalker Saga the filmmakers gather an
army of Jedi voices from the live-action
films and the fan favorite animated
series all assuring Rey there with her
you might not be able to distinguish
them all from one another but the
credits confirm that from the
live-action trilogies we hear samuel
l.jackson his mace windu Frank Oz is
Yoda Ewan McGregor is obi-wan Kenobi
Hayden Christensen is Anakin Skywalker
and Liam Neeson is quite Gon Jinn from
the animated series the Clone Wars and
Star Wars rebels the course includes
Angelique Perrin is aadi Galia ashley
eckstein as ahsoka tano Freddie Prinze
jr. as kana Joris Jennifer Hale as ila
Sakura and Olivia da boo is Luminara
Unduli if anything was ever meant to be
a love letter to Star Wars fans this is
it bringing together so many voices for
a single scene is something no one
expected and the course of Jedi ends
with Rey using Luke and Leia's crossed
lightsabers
as well as the power of all the Jedi who
came before her to bring a satisfying
final destruction to Emperor Palpatine
rogue whatta Star Wars story isn't a
movie with a lot of lightsaber duels
there are no colourful synth Jedi
clashes and no conflicting politics
within the Jedi Council
regardless Darth Vader makes two cool
appearances perhaps most memorably in a
hallway slaughter scene where he boards
the rebel command ship and relentlessly
cuts down the troops who've just
successfully uploaded the Death Star
plans the plan survived the hallway
attack but none of the rebels in the
hallway do well
the rebels in the following hallway
don't live either one finally races
through the airlock of the Tantive for
which just barely has time to detach
with Princess Leia on board ironically
while Vader doesn't feature much on rope
one this scene is arguably the single
most brutal Vader scene in the history
of Star Wars and if you can believe it
there's an even more violent version of
the scene that you can find on the
blu-ray in a way this was a scene Darth
Vader very much needed after the three
prequels which were filled with
masterfully choreographed lightsaber
duels the comparatively stiff lumbering
Darth Vader can sometimes make you
wonder how he was ever a threat the
rogue one hallway scene reminds you of
exactly what this monster is capable of
Carrie Fisher tragically died one year
before the release of the last Jedi a
fact that can't help but lend
heartbreaking power to certain scenes
fans and critics may always be divided
over the quality of the film but
regardless of feelings about the movie
you've got to have some heartstrings
pulled when Luke tells Leia
no one's ever really gone before he
kisses her tenderly on the forehead the
moment is a bit of serendipity it wasn't
planned at least the kiss wasn't Mark
Hamill told Entertainment Tonight that
he spontaneously decided to do it in the
middle of the take it just happened and
I was standing up and they were ready
for it and they said no do that again
and we did it for a second check Amal
said the scene was quote really
momentous for him because it represented
Luke saying goodbye to his sister
forever
unfortunately Hamill lost his friend
Fisher before the scene was shown in
theaters the actor said that because of
the loss he still can't watch the scene
she'll be forever missed and she's
irreplaceable check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]